du Sud 4 gars que vous avez peut-être
déjà croisé dans la rue à la verticale
voir à l'horizontale en tout cas
toujours agrippé au mobilier urbain
avec leur style sculptural ils auraient
pu figurer dans un opus bessonien car
oui c'est beau comme du cinéma rencontre
entre deux exploits avec ses pratiquants
de parcours parmi les meilleurs de nos
îles
je parcours pour moi ça fait deux ans
pour les plus anciens donc comme Florian
ça fait ça fait 5 ans
pour l'instant on fait beaucoup ça par
plaisir on essaye de monter notre
association et par la suite essayer
d'ouvrir une école pour faire connaître
ce sport là la Réunion
en fait c'est comme moi c'est quand je
suis arrivé au lycée j'ai connu ben les
gens qui ont formé le groupe les gens
dans la vie avec Tito etc Anthony Idir
et c'est là qui m'ont emmené sur le port
de Saint-Pierre pour la première fois et
c'est là que j'ai fait mes premiers
entraînements en fait
et donc voilà puis le reste ils ont fait
un peu de sport extrême avant de
commencer genre roller skate etc
par contre le seul sport où je me sens
vraiment bien où il y a un esprit qui
qui forme la personnalité et je pense
que c'est le sport le plus complet que
j'ai fait jusqu'à maintenant
il y a pas vraiment de compétition ici à
réunion Fatma mais on va dire là la
compétition vient d'être né dans
l'Europe mais à part ça le sport il est
pas vraiment de compétition on aimerait
qu'il y a des compétitions ici mais de
parcours plus que de salto etc en fait
c'était la GSX donc génération sensation
extrême on se déplace partout dans le
vide là c'est notre terrain de jeu à
Saint-Pierre donc venez nous voir à
bientôt